thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a scary
wild ride with Stevo we're here in
Australia where the time zone is so
wildly off and it's a different day and
when I wake up in the morning out here
I'm scared of what I'm gonna see on my
phone honestly because what's going on
with our buddy bam is genuinely
terrifying and uh he's been running from
the police
allegedly with an eight-year-old girl in
the car with his girlfriend and and on
like a crazy meth Bender all of this uh
according to TMZ reporting it's really
really gnarly stuff and um I uh I have a
lot to say about it you know I have a
lot to say about uh how I feel
um also uh aside from all of that the
what's been happening out here in
Australia is so utterly ridiculous with
the legal prostitution with the the
prison pocket demonstration I mean
you're not gonna believe the information
that you hear about the
the smuggling first-hand account the
smuggling
uh of of Contraband into prison uh man
that we really might have recorded the
most wildly entertaining and scary wild
ride ever so let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen
what am I saying me
they're the drivers
um
ladies and gentlemen me and Scott
Randolph and Vinnie are going to tell
you about the craziest week ever solo
pod number three yep might as well start
off with uh bam is running from the law
hiding in the woods threatening to kill
people this all according to TMZ it's
pretty unreal
um how long do you guys hear it before
it hits the news cycle or do you pretty
much hear about it as it hits the new
cycle okay
here's
oh wow glad you asked there's uh I'm not
necessarily glad you asked but there's
this um sub Reddit
strictly devoted to people talking about
Bam Margera and it is absolutely insane
how fast news develops on the let's talk
bam subreddit and um that's what it's
called let's talk bam let's talk bam
I've never been to Reddit before but I
just I heard about this bam page and and
I went and checked it out and uh
there are some resourceful people on
there and a lot of it's really funny a
lot of it's really sad a lot of it's uh
breaking news but um I'm pretty sure
that's where TMZ is getting all of the
Scoops is from Serenity you really think
TMZ is getting it from Reddit I think
people on Reddit are feeding it to TMZ
okay and
um you know the stuff breaks on Reddit
it goes to TMZ yeah but wow I mean we
have had the gnarliest week ever and I
don't even know where to begin with uh
the prostitutes with the the key
stirring but um I do want to just wrap
up the BAM talk a little bit
um she
found out about this this uh free bam
movement which is just the
the most lunatic stuff he's just finding
out about it now there's speculation
about whether he knew and forgot or
whether he's lying saying that he never
knew who knows but uh there's a
particular learning person in charge of
this whole operation and he found out
about this loony lady
and asked to do an interview with her
and uh according to a lot of people he's
many days into a meth Bender like
smoking crystal meth and drinking
alcohol and going to do interviews with
this loony lady and it seems that just
about as soon as he got out of uh her
presence
like he's assaulting people and
threatening to kill people and hiding in
the woods clearly the story about bam
hiding in the woods is not a joking
matter but it is worth asking my male
audience what are you hiding in your
Shrubbery down there I mean come on
dudes like ladies are not interested in
finding a bunch of Shrubbery with your
garbage they're not and that's why
manscaped is such a great sponsor of the
Wild Ride podcast and they're a great
company because they're saving people's
lives in this month of April which is
testicular cancer awareness month so
dudes let's support manscape let's clear
away the Shrubbery and the bush and
let's help with the cause of testicular
cancer by checking our nuggets and just
doing the right thing and buying these
products plus if you want to get a
killer deal on these products like the
lawnmower 4.0 the new weed whacker 2.0
get out of here I use this stuff all the
time man my nose here I'm on top of it
because of the weed whacker and if you
go to
manscaped.com and use the promo code
Stevo they will give you 20 off of your
order plus free shipping come on could
this be a better company it's manscaped
baby go to manscaped.com and use the
promo code Stevo 20 off your order free
shipping and saving lives now let's get
back to it recording this on Wednesday
American time and uh it'll come out on
Thursday and without a doubt in just the
24 hours between now and when this comes
out there will be lots of news like
that's what's so crazy about is
subreddit is that yeah it's pretty wild
I mean it's crazy that people are like
yeah come on my podcast and talk while
he's on meth like right that's kind of
gnarly I'm
I'm really glad that number one we never
had bam on the podcast when he was
intoxicated
he died allegedly allegedly but like I
mean but he was in a place where he
shouldn't have been well whenever we've
spoken to Bam on the podcast he's been
presentable yeah yeah yeah all right
he's been
lovely to deal with right right and when
he was on tour with us it was it wasn't
bad when he was on tour with us it was
awesome yeah and and uh I went ahead and
just scrapped all of that footage oh did
you scrap it it's never gonna see the
light of death I remember what are you
gonna do with it yeah yeah even though
it has its moments of heartwarming and
yeah we probably could have made a lot
of money if we sold those bam
skateboards for sure but it's all out
the window
so take that anybody who thinks uh God
I'm so glad I got one of those parts
yeah I made a lot of money too did you
you haven't even talked about what you
were going to do with that money too I
mean I did want to
um you know help create a trust fund for
Phoenix but then
um with Nikki filing for uh legal
separation Soul custody like this and
that like now there's a whole new
Wrinkle in it where you know we're going
to be talking about alimony we're going
to be talking about child support and
he's gonna have to pay that anyway so I
did suggest hey why don't we sell these
skateboards and have
um you know have uh money go straight to
cover
Phoenix child support alimony like
whatever like that's coming out of your
pocket either way and when I made that
suggestion
uh I got a call from a very drunk band
how dare you really I I did my work I
worked you know that's you know and I
was like
Bam um I've paid you for everything you
did I'm talking about anything in the
future you know that has not happened
yet for me to do more in the future yeah
I really just you know wouldn't and I
don't this is the first day that he uh
uh posted the challenge Knoxville to the
the oh to the boxing no glove box yeah
Jesus
I'm just
I you know I was I was laying in the in
the shower just laying on the ground
just soaking the the the the water over
me and thinking about it I was like this
craziness with bam I
what I'm so sad about is that
that if he was happy and healthy
like Not only would would he be thriving
if he was sober and and productive he'd
be thriving but the two of us would be
so much stronger together for sure I
mean you look at like
Tom Segura and Bert Kreischer and how
much stronger they are together because
of the two bears in one cave and stuff
and I just think about the opportunities
that we could have had yeah
but there are no opportunities because
all this is going on and and as far as
him being running from the cops and and
hiding in the woods like whatever is
going on I hope to God that he gets
arrested I hope to God that the family
because at that points the taxpayers are
just paying for him to go to jail and
detox right I mean that's kind of
instead of him coming out of pocket 50
Grand a month forget about like the
taxpayers paying the money it's more of
like maybe the actual jail time will
force him and give him enough time away
from the drugs right here it's like okay
I'm sober for a little bit that's the
one thing that it hasn't tried yet yeah
exactly and furthermore it's the like
and sitting in jail is the only place
where everybody can have a reasonable
expectation that he's safe yeah that
he's not harming himself or others is
that a good segue for jail talk
uh sure I mean my point with the
taxpayers was I remember like 15 years
ago or something when I was going
through it with a family member I was
watching Dr Drew and he was just like
you know if you're suspecting somebody's
drunk driving and it's been enough like
call the cops on them get them arrested
have them and I that just kind of always
stuck out with me but that's why I
brought that up and if uh with all of
these people are saying that uh that
he's smoking meth I've always been
pretty careful not to make that
allegation myself even though
um you know like it would seem that it'd
be pretty easy to set up uh
some situation where you could be
arrested for that that'd probably be the
best thing that ever happened to him
yeah but it sounds like his charges now
are a little bit more serious than that
yeah they're all misdemeanors they're uh
terroristic threats for telling multiple
people he wants to put a bullet in their
head a terrorist threat is just a
misdemeanor I want to put a bullet in
your head is what earned the terroristic
threat as I understand it and it's on he
didn't get a charge for taking the car
no no charge for taking the car because
uh it was legitimately borrowed to his
crazy girlfriend and she just never gave
it back
and that's how he inherited a daughter
uh so he's talking about how he has a
daughter now yeah he's talking about how
he has a daughter and with all of this
crazy psycho stuff it seems that this
poor eight-year-old girl is in tow being
subjected to all of it it was a point
when like in and around where the car
was taken that uh apparently the
eight-year-old girl was left uh April's
right yeah with April yeah and uh I mean
I guess the I guess there's a break you
know that she's not with bam running
from the cops and you know uh with all
the things going on but
I for April I mean if he goes to jail at
least you can sign relief where she
knows where she he is yeah right that's
like uh okay now I know he's not in the
[__] Woods yeah I hope to God that he
doesn't die I hope to God that the band
the family will press charges do
whatever it takes to get him because
it's the one thing we haven't seen yet
we haven't tried that yet I think that
jail I think maybe I'm so scared of
being in jail that that's the one thing
but do you think with these charges not
being that serious he'll actually get
but there's so many charts I mean like
wouldn't it four or five but wouldn't a
judge look at the last four years and be
like
hopefully okay then let me ask you this
would would somebody like bam go to uh
protective custody where they go like in
the mix with everybody or get like
custody for sure the whole time yeah
yeah he would be absolutely totally safe
there's no way that they would let him
be in contact prisoners other other
inmates there's no way and and for that
matter anytime somebody with uh any kind
of Fame
is in jail there's no upside for the
jail something bad happens to that
person the Jail's screwed for like like
all of a sudden that Jail's under a
microscope like they they want to get
celebrities kind of out of there because
there's no benefit to the jails for
having them in there is my understanding
which doesn't help the kids because it
would be better if if uh if he was in
there okay but you think it would be
better if he was in general no no no I
just think it'd be better if he was in
jail oh if he was in jail in general
yeah I think that that you know but it's
just so scary man it's so scary like how
crazy and and bad this is like now like
I was afraid when I woke up today in
Australia we're so many hours ahead that
we wake up and it's already evening back
home and I'm like what happened today
you know am I gonna turn on my phone
turn off do not disturb and find out
terrible news do you think that Bam's
like so addicted to meth that if when he
does get caught and goes to jail he's
going to key through some meth to get in
there
I see what you did there
I mean we did just learn a lot about the
art of keystring it really is an art huh
it wasn't art you were pretty methodical
about it yeah yeah I mean dear it's very
great segue our buddy Vinnie here went
to jail for six months yeah we talked
about this with the Maynard from Tool
yeah we've talked about it with with a
number of people and um it started off
with Knoxville right that started off
with Knoxville yeah
uh when we weren't even recorded we were
just hanging out I just thought it would
be really funny to start talking about
prison Pockets right and now I'm just
known as prison pocket Vinnie yeah so
you went to jail for six months badly
addicted to heroin yeah and brought when
you so you surrendered yourself yeah I
surrendered where where did you
surrender yourself it's a court
um was it at like a a court yeah like an
actual Courthouse would you get caught
for
um that charge was for a larceny larceny
is anything over 1500 no anything under
not larceny six under anything under
fifteen hundred dollars okay yeah and um
Okay so
I know that when I had my second drunk
driving arrest I showed up to the
arraignment was it the arraignment like
uh and um
and I asked like I want to plead guilty
and just can I turn myself in now like
uh I don't want to go all the way home
and then come all the way back and then
just get it all done and just get over
with yeah yeah all right did you do that
no we were trying to fight it at this
one I had a a really shitty lawyer
um but when you were living in a porta
potty you had a shitty lawyer yeah
it was the it was the advertisement on
the porta potty he's like huh maybe I
can call this guy yeah
um no this was actually before the porta
potty like a pretty good while before it
but um
yeah I I went to court a few times just
trying to like get my sentence lowered
you know I just keep fighting it and
eventually they offered what they gave
me what does that even look like does
that mean that you had a trial
um no it was more of like okay we go in
I talked to my lawyer he goes okay this
is what they're going to offer you I
said it wasn't a court date no it wasn't
a court date and then I go in he says
okay the judge is offering you this much
I either accept or decline and how was
he offering you the first one was like
over a year and I was like no [__] that
second one was like nine months no [__]
that and then like the cap was like six
months
um and the charge again was for Percocet
pills no this one was for larceny six
and I got this jail time because I've
had a couple felon felonies before that
once larceny six me larceny six is just
stealing stuff
under uh fifteen hundred dollars like
that's the value of under fifteen
hundred dollars so so it was like it's
kind of like white like a white lie it's
like white stealing so what I would oh
God uh so what I would do is I would
like go into
um
like grocery stores with like a shopping
cart and I would take
like the 12 cases of Red Bull and
Monster and then I would just take them
to my local Bodega and sell them for a
dollar piece
to the bodega man yeah that's pretty
that's like good guy theft yeah yeah
it's just junky theft like when I was
homeless it's been like Robin of larceny
back in uh like the beginning of 1994.
my ammo was uh
to um like I would do like a backflip or
just something you know like something
for like you know 25 cents I'd come up
with 25 cents maybe I'd even just beg
for 25 cents and then like I'd be able
to buy like a loaf of bread for like 50
cents but when I went in to go buy the
loaf of bread like I would tuck a pack
of hot dogs into like my my coat yeah
and then so that buying the loaf of
bread was more of an exercise and like
making sure that nobody appeared to be
on to me
so I knew as I made a legitimate
purchase yeah like you know stole the
hot dogs bought the bread and then I
would take that all over to the 7-Eleven
and use their microwave to cook the hot
dogs oh okay yeah yeah and use all their
condiments to load up the the hot dogs
you guys would never buy beer and like
tuck your pant leg into your shoe and
just stick 40s down your leg it never
did that
all right
no okay so minor theft you go and now
you got to go to jail for six months
yeah and you're when do you turn
yourself into jail when did I well I
mean I'm just saying like you uh you
read The Plea they they so they gave me
like a couple days and I had to come
back to the courthouse to turn myself in
and then I put me in cuffs and put me in
the back of the Paddy Wagon
okay yeah and uh and put you in the back
of the Paddy Wagon at that point are you
already key straight already key student
okay so you knew what the plea deal was
gonna be yeah and you were like all
right I know I'm going to the courthouse
I know I'm gonna accept six months I
know I'm gonna be dub sick so I'm
putting a bunch of stuff up you headed
up your butt in the courthouse yeah
yeah and so you had uh you said 10
bundles no 10 Xanax bars 10 Xanax bars
yeah two bundles so there's ten packs of
heroin per bundle yeah but remember the
packs of dope are tiny it's like it's
like it's one fix yeah no no no one
bundle can get me like through a few
days if I if I if I ration it yeah but
that if I'm if I'm home I'm not doing
that I'm not rationing like that's like
ordering a Happy Meal and
savory fries yeah yeah
yeah who does that
okay yeah okay so so one bundle can get
you through three days if you're deaf if
yeah if I'm really and you've had 20
bundles no I had 20 bags two bundles
each bundle has ten bags
okay so each bundle has so one bag yeah
is one fix yeah
so you had two bags fixes two bags so
you can get through one a week yeah if
you're a desperate yeah yeah yeah it
lasted me a little over a week
so what did you do after the workout to
that later yeah so you got uh 20 bags
two bundles yes and you've got uh two
grams of tobacco yeah two packs of
Rolling Papers yeah
um 10 Xanax bars yes and a hypodermic
needle yeah all wrapped around with
Saran Wrap yes and then a condom over
the whole thing double wrapped with
condoms double wrapped with condoms yeah
and the size of that lengthwise about
six inches maybe
um no maybe five four so it's like a
like a cigar like a yeah standard-ish
for sure good and thicker yeah yeah and
right up the old poop shoot yeah and
when I did it the first time when I did
the first time I didn't give a f I
didn't care what would happen to me
because like right you know there's so
many things that can go wrong when you
did it the first time I mean when you're
putting needles up your butt
yeah what could possibly be ready
I didn't care you know
um
because yeah because there's a [__]
needle in my keister so right so it's
keister a scientific term no I don't
think okay
all right so so you you go to the court
with this in there yeah then then you
agree to the plea deal yeah they
handcuffed you in the courtroom yeah in
The Paddy Wagon yeah now they're going
to take you over to the the city jail
yeah and for to be processed into jail
and then presumably you'll be processed
into there and then transported over to
more of a County Jail yeah
and um
for uh
for you to feel like you were settled in
there like not under the radar and ready
to remove the package from your keister
took a little over 24 hours a little
over 24 hours yeah because it takes a
while for
for you to get settled in you know
um like you you got to go through so
many things you got to see it like uh
go through so many like checkbox shots
yeah right exactly and uh did they ask
you to uh lift up your ball sack and
it'll cost so they did but they didn't
like
Peak super hard I mean they would have
to lift some folds yeah
for sure right yeah
um so but like and all that was also
terrifying you know I'm like oh [__]
they're gonna find all this up me right
now and that's another charge
major felony and by the way as where as
this story unfolds keep in mind we
haven't even gotten to the prostitute
action that we had this week yeah it's
been a heavy week it's been a really
really heavy week yeah and um thank God
we've got so much to talk about because
uh it means a lot to me when we do a
podcast without a guest yeah but back to
your uh 24 hours in yeah where are you
in one of these huge kind of gymnastics
I'm in a dorm I'm in a dorm and I'm on
top bunk which sounds like the museum
and it's got it's filled with bunks
Maybe
maybe 30 bucks maybe more than that 40
bucks detoxing at this point
um I'm starting to feel sick yeah um and
I'm just like oh my God I need to get
this out of me I need to get loaded
somehow and um but 24 hours later you
know I'm like okay I think I feel safe
enough where I could just like go to the
toilet and try to get this thing out of
me and that's what I did and
and it was the best thing that's because
I knew like I was going to be so sick
aren't there cameras in the toilets or
can't they see what's going on no
there's cameras like not you're not in
the toilets there's cameras on
everything you could possibly do maybe
except yeah yeah except the dump taking
a dump and taking a shower
oh that's why so much violence goes down
in the shower huh yeah
um that's why they say don't drop the
soap and it's worth mentioning too that
the type of heroine that you had in your
keister was not the kind that you have
to cook in a spoon I think I think the
Layman pictures like oh heroin in order
to shoot up here when you have to cook
it in a spoon yeah that's if you're
using black tar heroin yeah when you had
that powdered China White exactly so all
you have to do with the powdered China
White is simply mix it well just yeah
mix it with water preferably purified
water but you didn't care I would have
mixed it with Port-A-Potty water
the blue liquid
I mean I've used some crazy [__] to mix
my mix my stuff up before right yeah so
uh I can see you go to the the toilet
yeah poop it out this is the better than
any Christmas morning you've ever for
sure yeah I'm on top of the world right
um where do you begin to unwrap the
package every right there right in the
toilet yeah right in the toilet I don't
even I don't even wait till like I get
right right there you don't even know
right you get right with God right yeah
yeah you become one with the universe
yeah and uh and so are other people
waiting to use the toilet or I don't
think so no is this like the middle of
the night it was middle of the night
yeah okay so you get right you're so
happy you're able to flush down the um
all the condoms everything you don't
need yeah everything that remains stinks
pretty bad
yeah yeah for sure and then this story
just gets crazier and crazier and
speaking of things stinking really bad
there are some habits that make you
stink really bad and you might need to
quit that habit so what's the best way
to do it replace a bad habit with a good
habit and the best way for me
that's what I'm talking about right here
it's this device it's got a completely
natural flavored core so you can replace
electronic gadgets with that
with this a simple thing man I love fume
and if you go to try fume.com that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use the promo code
Stevo then you can get 10 off your order
right now now ask yourself do I really
need to do something is it time for me
to quit my bad habits yeah well
go to
trifum.com and use the promo code Stevo
because I think the answer is yes all
right let's get back to it and I would
just like to go back to my bunk you know
I I don't feel safe enough safe enough
keeping it in my pockets so like I'll
like keep it in my butt cheeks right you
know for most of the time yeah and then
like I'll go to my bunk because I stash
it in your sheets on your back because
they check your sheets and stuff like
randomly you don't know when it's gonna
happen they might not at all you know
but like that again that's another
charge so you don't wanna
I'm loving this story how long are you
in the gymnasium type setup with all the
bunk beds before you get into it no I
was in there the whole time Oh I thought
you said you had a selling no it was uh
yeah my bunky so wait you you [__] it
out do you rig up right there right
there you pop a Xanax right there so you
that's and then you smoke a cigarette uh
no I didn't smoke at the time because I
was afraid I didn't even draw attention
and then they'd come in yeah you see
smoke outside so that was your deal you
rigged up popped the Xanax and then you
walked back like and then yeah
did you rig up and then Papa's Xanax or
Papa Xanax first you gotta wait for the
Xanax to come oh no I popped the Xanax
and then rig but I'm not waiting for the
Xanax to call and I pop it sure of
course yeah but you're not you're not
gonna shoot up and then pop Xanax you
can pop Xanax and then shoot yeah yeah
can you imagine this guy walking back to
the [__] bug you look at the cameras
and you're just like I'm just [__]
I mean we've got to be so obvious dude
I'd like to I'd like to think that I hit
it pretty well you had the same bunk bed
for the whole six months the whole six
months you're in the same room yeah the
top bunk and like when I was out of all
the drugs and I got dope sick I was on
the top bunk and it was the worst worst
feeling I've ever had in my life I was
[__] my pants like it was
um
you didn't go without drugs the whole
time right well it's like okay I I'm
done with mine it's not the easiest
finding more in jail you know it's like
I don't like this so like I try to keep
to myself and only stick with a few
people but me I I probably got loaded on
other people's [__] maybe
five times the whole time I was there
how did you pay for it just store stuff
okay help with stores you know you get
like like commissary yeah commissary
like Cookie Balls or coffee balls or I
guess honey buns that's commissary stuff
which requires you to have money on your
book for sure did were people putting
money on your books um my mom put a
little bit of money on my books but that
was about it
okay yeah she was like over my [__] and
like
she's weird yeah I was like why would
you like that yeah can you believe it
so what about uh would you ever like
forego a meal to be able to trade your
uh like a hot meal yeah like a
um no yeah that's not your ammo no yeah
what about like prison debt were you
worried about going in the debt no no
you ever get any fights in prison nope
no everybody thought I was Puerto Rican
in prison so it's like I learned more
Spanish in there than I did in school
wow okay all right well so you were sick
most of the time yeah for a while and um
at no point you did you think man this
is a like a real gift that I'm I'm
detoxing in jail
um now I could just stay sober no I
didn't think of it as like oh it's a
real gift like how we were talking with
bam that it might work like that it was
more of like oh my God this is a
miserable existence I'm never gonna go
back to that [__] ever again
this is a miserable existence I'm never
gonna go without heroin again
that's what you thought no no no
wow
when you got out of out of prison I went
right back into it but but how long were
you sober for before you got out of
prison uh maybe
um a couple months so you didn't yeah
you're two months clean yeah and the
whole and the whole time I'm like oh I'm
never I'm done I'm done using I'm done
doing everything that I was doing and
this night I'm out how did that happen
okay wow the night that you're out now
you haven't had a fix for two months
yeah like is it on your mind that that
when when people fix up after because
your tolerance is so low
are we worried I'm gonna OD and die no I
never worry about that because I'm just
focused on getting as close to death as
possible you're never worried about the
overdose you're just terrified of the
the the underdosed
yeah exactly yeah and we were kind of
getting into it you you have overdosed
yeah 15 times oh my God that's right
yeah and how many of those times were
you legally dead three maybe four times
what's the difference between an
overdose and being legally dead well
overdose it's like
he stopped breathing for a little bit
and then you come back to it without any
like external help you know like uh like
experimental health I mean like like
Narcan and [__] like that Narcan CPR uh
defibrillator yeah yeah yeah I I there's
I I've been I've woken up from an
overdose with a tube down all the way
down my throat my arms tied so I like
and then I was in the middle of Vermont
and uh in some dude's house and I I wake
up and I feel this thing all the way
down my throat and the first thing I do
is I'm like I'm freaking out so I'm
trying to pull it out but they take my
arms down I'm just like the paramedics
the paramedics yeah and the first thing
that came in I had like a bunch of
heroin in this dude's closet so the
first thing that came to my mind was I
hope they didn't find My Heroine you
know it's like that's how sick that's
how [__] sick it is you know it's
it's crazy
so the night you get out of jail you're
you're back on I don't think my mom
knows about any of these overdoses
that's crazy yeah
um it did it's a heartwarming story and
and having discussed your prison pocket
you know and uh much shorter yeah terms
yeah before this was a more of a deep
dive fascinating
um but because we've been discussing a
prison pocket we thought why don't we do
a prison pocket demo yeah
and that's one of the greatest things
that has happened in a long time in my
life oh wow yeah I'm honored yeah and um
we did that here in Australia it's so
ironic too that Australia is very
difficult to get into
and uh you know if you're a criminal if
you've got arrests particularly felonies
which you have you're a felon yeah and
so we came to Australia before and you
were never even allowed in yeah then we
went home and came back for this second
leg of the Australian tour and we were
managed so now we're in Australia yeah
the whole time you guys were here me and
Scott and Isaac were just going back and
forth with the attorneys just like
trying to make it happen right and
Australia is so touchy about felonies
that it's just beautiful and poetic that
we chose while you're in Australia to
celebrate your uh your first pocket
so we wrapped up uh we put together a
bundle yeah for your a prison Rock and
it was a health bundle yeah if the first
one for for jail was five inches this
one had to be like seven inches yeah it
was
it was a lot bigger longer and wider
we put two
two pods in there for God's sakes that
yeah that's uh yeah what else did you
put in the video when you said when you
like uh point to the espresso part and
say that's the size of my butthole
a lot of people would consider that a
pretty gaping buddy
I know I know
this huge package and and you just went
for it yeah and I struggled at first
and then I just turned it I didn't see a
lot of struggles he was acting like he
was struggling
I saw an angry bulldog
I was thinking before before we went
into it I was thinking I was like oh man
if I get this thing really easy should I
just act and pretend I'm happy I'm in
trouble that's a good call yeah so we
get it up there virtually without issue
yeah no issue but you um
you were like like badly like very
gingerly limping around like to the
point where if I was a correctional
officer in a jail and I saw you walking
like that I'd be like hey buddy yeah get
over here yeah like and um you you were
scared to sit down you were in great
discomfort yeah no pain just discomfort
yeah we got to dinner
and you said
man I gotta go to the bathroom and push
this thing up further yeah so you go to
the bathroom push it up further come
back to the table nothing's changed
except later in the dinner all of a
sudden you go oh get this one up yeah
like totally it's just so weird like the
time delay between you pushing up
further and then maybe another 10 15
minutes yeah and then oh it just went up
and once it did and and presumably what
you were talking about it going up it
went past what's called your inner
butthole yeah there's an inner butthole
and it it just your your inner butthole
just swallowed the package yeah once it
went past you're in her butthole all of
a sudden the discomfort was gone the
discomfort everything was gone I
couldn't even feel it in there you
didn't even notice I didn't even know it
was in there that's why I I was getting
more I was it was free that was what was
freaking me out just not being able to
feel it right because you can't even
tell it's in there yeah it's so far up
yeah now it becomes a real question of
whether it's going to come out exactly
because we know that there have been so
many people we we spoke with uh the
famous plastic surgeon Dr Terry Dubrow
of the show botched and he told us about
how he understands every emergency room
has a special drawer where they keep
objects which were like surgically
removed from people's butts that's great
yeah I forget there's like uh yeah I
remember talking about it I don't
remember it seems pretty wild that they
would do that but he he had that story
and you would have joined the legions of
of uh
people who have gone to the hospital
with that issue yeah thank God that
didn't happen all right
we guys went to the hospital yeah we
will before that right true to the
prison pocket demo we made sure that you
kept it up your butt for a solid 24
hours yeah and after dinner
we went and played bowling yeah is that
we call you and played bowling yeah yeah
we went bowling and uh you beat
everybody yeah because you guys [__]
suck and
um yeah after like well I mean dude it
was so funny it was it was so good like
hopefully I haven't had that much fun
bowling in a very long time
there's lives
YouTube yeah you know and we can direct
everybody to the prison pocket yeah yeah
slash prostitution video yeah oh my God
so this so then you go
after bowling we all go back to the
hotel we sleep for the night if you wake
up the next morning and you're actually
like a little bit scared yeah
um I was pretty nervous I just didn't
know
I didn't like so many things were going
through my head like worst case scenario
things like am I gonna oh because in the
in the package with the two espresso
pods included three yeah three AAA
batteries yeah we did not have a single
good thing about putting AAA batteries
yeah it is very important to be careful
about what you put in your body and
that's why I start every day with
athletic greens man I'm telling you this
stuff fills in all the gaps in my diet
it's comprehensive convenient nutrition
and it is so delicious now I'm gonna
admit something here that
I've got a new habit which is mixing my
ag1 from athletic greens with a lot less
water than they recommend because it's
just so tasty man I like it to be a
stronger mix
so yeah I uh you know I enjoy it a lot I
can't say enough about how delicious
this stuff is and how good it makes me
feel about my nutrition man it also
makes me feel good about my cognitive
abilities my gut health and everything
man I'm telling you it's like one stop
shopping and if you go to
athleticgreens.com Stevo
then you will get five of these
comprehensive convenient ag-1 travel
packs plus a year's supply of immune
boosting vitamin D I mean you can't beat
it I use this step every day I love the
convenient travel packs when I'm on tour
and uh you're gonna love them too so one
more time go to athletic greens.com
Stevo and get a load of how delicious
this stuff is yeah dude let's get back
to it not one person said that that was
a good idea yeah yeah
yeah when he told the doctors too they
were it was like a game changer for them
yeah because I I was like I was like
yeah so I'm on tour with Stevo and
things got a little crazy last night I
have some things up my butt yeah and
then the guy's like oh this is great
what are we talking yeah and he said he
grabs a pen and paper and he starts
writing everything down and then and
he's like kind of giggling while I'm
telling him all these things oh yeah
this is fine yeah and when I said yeah I
have three AAA batteries he just like no
more smile no more nothing he just
looked at me and he's like you really
have three AAA batteries up your ass
right now I was like yeah yeah he goes
Jesus Christ you know like and then he
like made a phone call and right yeah
and so that and then seeing his face
made me more nervous and that was Mary
bro right oh we forgot to mention that
that there was also like a proper metal
pen yeah in your in your butt too we had
two espresso pods three AAA batteries uh
a pen four sheets of paper and five
Skittles yeah and um
and they would and then we we get extra
Pan the pen wasn't even an issue no the
pin he was nobody was tripping about the
pen no nobody's tripping about that even
though there was a sharp Point yeah and
that was the other thing that was kind
of scaring me too like
like I'm I'm sober now so of course I'm
gonna worry about pointing things up my
butt you know like back then I didn't
care so now now I'm just like freaking
out and uh thinking worst case scenarios
and uh so they they set you up for an
x-ray but it was like not cheap right
like was it before 900 bucks for the
first round yeah like it was like
hundreds of dollars before even getting
to the X-ray wasn't it like it was like
900 no not four but not including the
X-ray I don't know I don't know if
they're gonna be sending me an invoice
via email or not oh well did we not pay
for it well you guys paid for the
original nine the 900 I don't know if
that includes the X-ray I mean of course
I know yeah but so then
we're now approaching 24 hours since he
put it up there yeah and they they set
you up for an extra we go in for the
X-ray yeah
when the X-ray I'm in the X-ray room
which I'm not supposed to be in they
were like really touchy about cameras
but but uh they let us film yeah and so
I film you getting the X-ray it shows up
on the screen and as a Layman my first
reaction was ah man like
like why didn't those metal espresso
pods show up they're metal I was so
disappointed that I couldn't see the
metal espresso pods on the screen with
the X-ray all I saw was the three
batteries and the metal pen yeah and and
my initial reaction was one of
disappointment until I I uh looked away
and looked back and realized that the
more like kind of a shadowy very
distinct
like outline of the whole package and
when you realize like when you see it
that way it's like wow yeah that's a
monster package it really was I I didn't
like dude the thing when I went when I
went to prison it was not that big right
it was not that big when you went to
prison did it go up the second butthole
yeah yeah but yeah for sure but it was
like it was way smaller you know so it's
like like and again I was high and
loaded I didn't care you know right so
we get the X-ray by the time we notice
like how you can actually see how
monstrous that package is were elated
we're so happy with these x-rays we
waited extra time for them to print out
because at first they said they wouldn't
give it to us didn't they say that
they're like no we can't give you
something because I said can you burn it
onto a CD for us and you said no we
can't do that you're really lucky that
we're letting you shoot the screen with
your cell phone to get it that way yeah
and then all of a sudden as an
afterthought they're like hey we could
print you up a physical film copy of it
yeah we're like hell yes we've got this
like poster size like it's so sick yeah
yeah and um we leave the hospital we go
to The Venue where we've got the show
that night and it's time for well before
we leave the hospital I was like Steve
like you give me the green light to poop
and you're like not without me bub
yeah
without a camera on camera yeah and so I
said okay like uh let's grab a camera
and poop in the
this ain't it but
he goes to jail
yeah I get deported real quick yeah
we go to The Venue we go into a bathroom
I go with you I'm filming yeah and you
sit on the toilet and like right away
you're able to poop yep
um and and you're like dude it was just
poop like I only like I only pooped and
now I don't have any herbs like I don't
think I can poop anymore like and I said
that's that's when I got really I was
like oh no right and then I said Minnie
the the X-ray was expensive enough
please
just pretty much Guilt Trip
right and then
super bummed like like scared you know
and then like minutes had gone by yeah
and Vinnie just gets the thought to just
turn around and look at the end of the
toilet and he pukes into the toilet and
he goes oh it came out that's what came
out yeah that was just a little piece of
poo was this gigantic
yeah you weren't wondering why it wasn't
smelling in there no it was oh it smells
oh yeah it smelled real bad yeah it
smelled real bad so we got
we get the you know now the job's down
we've pooped it out so everything we're
all good you know we're out of the woods
so and it stinks so bad in the bathroom
I'm like I gotta get the hell out of
here so I go over to the green room
where they set us up with all of our
stuff to be backstage and I asked for a
coffee maker that will take the espresso
pots instead that Vinnie can make his
coffee and um they they bring it to us
we make the Vinnie eats the five
Skittles he drinks the he drinks his
double shot of espresso he uh lays out
the the four pieces of paper and writes
and these are tiny little pieces yeah
and he writes a four-page letter to his
mom did we mail it yet no not yet oh God
for God's sakes
her letter yeah we'll get it done i
writes this hilarious dear Mom you know
the boys and I are having a blast in
Australia you should have seen the
sunset when I was sticking this huge
package at my butt is your mom gonna
like that yeah yeah yeah she'll find it
hilarious the fact that she's gonna be
reading this letter on the pages that
we're at that were in my is so beautiful
yeah and he wrote the four-page letter
with the pen yeah ate the Skittles drank
the coffee which only left this three
AAA batteries yeah and I'm like well and
those were the most controversial like
item and we need to figure out what'd
you do with the batteries well that's
the thing is that I was like well now
we've got to put the batteries to use so
I I with my phone I Googled what
Electronics take AAA batteries and um
what stood out in the list was bathroom
scale Sarah's like oh man why don't we
let this like just you know I I got on
my Instagram and asked for a fan to
bring a bathroom scale that takes AAA
batteries
rad dude showed up right away wearing a
Slayer shirt yeah super super rad dude
named Christian and uh he brought a
scale that took four AAA batteries so we
used all three of of ours and put it in
the scale and uh it essentially began
this crazy fitness challenge because
what did you weigh when you stepped on
that scale yeah it was 292 pounds I
forget what it was for the uh 292 pounds
is and you've found that out
130 kilos yeah yeah something like that
yeah you found that out because we
powered that scale with three AAA
batteries that were up here but yeah he
weighed himself to get on his first
private jet yeah oh that's right because
we already needed a scale anyway yeah
yeah in order to figure out what we did
yeah because Isaac
this just gets better and better yeah
and I were looking for a skill and you
guys were already looking for a skin
yeah separately yeah because we like and
this is this is pretty amazing as like
testimony to how devoted you are to to
my team yeah I've said that like you
know you call Vinnie at four in the
morning and he and he'll answer the
phone and apologize for being asleep
yeah
you need Benny to drive the van to Texas
he's like when do you want me to leave
you know like whatever it is like you're
just you're the ultimate ride or die
Team Member yeah and we because we've
had problems with this bus which we're
on right now breaking down and
hitchhiking and this and that we were
like okay look the second leg in
Australia we're getting private jets for
the longer Drive yeah but we we got the
cheapest possible private jet which only
allowed us to to see four people
citation Mustangs
and you would be our fifth person yeah
so I told you hey Vinnie come to
Australia but we're all going to be on
private jet and you're going to be stuck
on the bus that may or may not make it
yeah yeah yeah yeah and you were like
aye aye Captain I was like I think I
said all right I think me and Dave are
going to be best friends yeah you said
you said I'm stoked I'm stoked whatever
I'll be on the bus and then like when we
got out here all of a sudden we were
thinking man like how do we get Vinnie
on the plane and the answer was really
limit how much luggage we have way
everybody and so that's why we needed
the scale it was insane how was your
first I mean that was a cool jet yeah it
was so sick I'm not I'm like I'm not
gonna lie I got a little emotional I bet
yeah I got super emotional because like
this goes back to that to that that dude
dude whoever like who yeah the god guy
who whatever that Kook was or whatever
happened that was right
if anybody's wondering about this story
we went into that one in pretty good
detail with me with Maynard yeah and and
it's like
whether that I I don't even know it's
just like the way that things the way
that things have been happening within
the last few months it's just like
unreal and when we were on that jet I
just I was just like reflecting on the
last just the last few years right you
know and just uh and it made me like
recognize like every year has been like
a level up level up level up and I've
only been sober for five years five
years ago I was homeless so be from that
five years ago to be on a private jet
with you guys it's just like Jesus dude
like yeah yeah there's a lot of special
things that happened to me when I first
started working with Steve too because I
got sober and then I went back to City
College I was like okay well what am I
gonna do and and I took this history
class and I learned about like maybe
five or six different cities in the
United States and then the first year we
started traveling I went to all those
cities so that was like that's cool that
was like I was like whoa you know yeah I
mean not to take it away from you but
like that cool story
[Laughter]
it's crazy because like now like like
I'm I'm there's been a lot of times in
the last like year where I'm just like
[__] am I making the right decisions am
I doing the right things as far as like
career and stuff you know and and I just
within the last couple months I'm
starting to feel a change yeah in the
career aspect you and I have had talks
about that yeah you know and um and and
uh you know it I I told you some stuff
that you didn't want to hear yeah and uh
and I told you because I felt that there
was in your best interest yeah and uh
you know and now everything's really
working out and I want to give you like
genuine praise and and encouragement
just props for what you're doing with
this new sketch comedy stuff oh thanks
dude I mean like you on your own
initiative with your own budget you're
professionally producing all of these
sketch comedy skits yeah and when you
showed it to me like I was genuinely
like deeply laughing out loud like I I
love what you're doing yeah thanks dude
I was I was
I wanted to wait a little longer to show
you because I know you're a tough cookie
to crack on on a lot of things you know
I mean I'm not gonna kiss your ass
exactly I don't like something no
exactly so that's why I wanted to wait a
little bit but I was just like you know
what I'm like really I'm really stoked
on this yeah yeah but also he's he has
expertise to give you that will help
yeah so it's a fine line between getting
drilled and like getting help yeah no
for sure I mean maybe notes and you
Incorporated them yeah and I think we
both agree that it helped yeah for sure
yeah and then with your your graphic for
your T-shirt design like I was super
stoked to help with that yeah
um can I can I can we talk about
prostitutes
I want to segue before we do that and I
want there's two maybe two two or three
things I want to talk about one can we
talk about uh since we are doing a solo
podcast are we giving away anything on
that
thank you for that every time that this
is the third time this uh you know but
whenever the the guest says it doesn't
say against it says Stevo and there's
some image that that uh it's not a guest
yeah
um that we've always given away stuff
generous it's like a little Easter egg
on the podcast right so you know
whenever it's in whenever there's not a
guest on the Wild Ride podcast you know
we're giving stuff away and candidly
we're doing that because we really
really want to be able to do podcasts
that are successful without having to
book a guest so it's our way of kind of
uh giving the the episodes without the
guest it's the little nudge you know
there's an incentive for for that so our
giveaway for the for this no guest
podcast it's it's not is it a giveaway
are we doing your call boss
these death metal shirts the the Steel
Death Metal shirt I think it's so
fantastic and how many do we have
I think we have maybe I can't even read
that and then there's the Blood T-shirt
we got the blood piece we got the the
the jackets
bomber jackets don't do the bomber
jacket I think they're epic okay so save
them for winter so the death metal T and
the blood tea they'll be at the front of
your website
0.0 all you have to pay is shipping okay
cool and hurry up because uh because
yeah like with that because we're giving
them away yeah because probably by this
point all the audio people are gonna be
on it so get on it before it even makes
it to YouTube it's probably gonna be
already gone but that's cool though I
mean I'm worried about the YouTube like
when we put a Maynard like the numbers
it took real like uh like 24 hours for
that to finally get the yeah we might I
mean there's some kind of Shadow
something going on with our YouTube
numbers man okay and then the second
thing I want to talk about is we're on
the bus Incognito yeah yeah our bus like
I
had some feelings about like uh the the
content we put out where it's like our
bus broke down granted an Australia
buses are not a thing this is the only
bus you could get it did break down but
the guy Dave the guy who owns and drives
the bus is the best he's the sickest
he's probably the most epic person in
the world yeah yeah we love him
Incognito nightliners check him out we
love him and uh the bus did break down
on this leg too but he fixed it so fast
it only broke down because it went up a
really Steep Hill yeah yeah well we did
travel on 4 500 feet up in the air yeah
and it did overheat but he got it fixed
and and he's the best he's the best if
you know so so we wanted to give some
love to the bus to the company to the
driver and the owner yeah
Incognito okay now I have a question for
you that I've been dying to ask you and
we can get to the prostitute after this
but it's also we're
it's a bunch of prostitutes
like there was a lot of communications
and negotiations oh yeah yeah okay yeah
um but let me so so we're on the side of
the road when the bus was overheating at
one point and our goal is to try to get
Vinnie to like 30 000 followers 50 000
like we want to blow Vinnie up oh that's
another thing is that on the Steve Aoki
I was gonna bring that up yeah we got a
knot sit on this forever yeah like you
want to have a winner chosen before well
you already read us a couple names and I
have I mean I haven't picked somebody
out you told me about like uh I feel
like one yes yeah they were both sober a
couple
or is that another person I don't know I
after this we I can go by the time I
record the intro for this episode I will
announce in the intro which is tomorrow
yeah okay um so we're on the side of the
road and we're like coming up with ideas
for Vinnie to go viral and you know we
were like this way that you came up with
the the Ant Hill I was saying it and I
was like saying or you gotta walk into a
spider web with a spider right there in
your face and he's like no [__] way
the Ant Hill glory hole is pretty epic
when you showed me uh you texted me a
picture I did yeah yeah you text me a
picture like ant hills have holes yeah
they're like just they look like a glory
hole Yeah okay straight up from the
Porky's movie Post Yeah so where I'm
going with this is Vinnie's just like no
[__] way I'm like Vinnie you're not
in a situation where you want to turn
down these stunts and he's like I have
he's like I've paid my dues and I was
like have you and then we were we had an
ongoing discussion about it these are
never paid bro
for sure no but I would say
but then I I just said like it's not
like you know like I feel like that's
your guys's dues are paid I mean if you
want that's how higher yeah yeah yeah
yeah then it's a question of when that
was my question when is somebody's dues
paid in this line of work of like doing
stuff
yeah I don't like uh it's just like what
do you mean by dues are paid you know I
I kind of meant it by like I mean you've
paid your dues so that you don't have to
share a hotel room anymore yeah yeah
yeah but when your career is in
providing entertainment for sure you're
not like you're doing what your dues are
paid it's like saying Stephen King's
dues are paid yeah he's gonna stop
writing books no no it was more of like
I I think I've paid enough dues to wear
and I'm not even noticed that where I'm
not even talking about stuff with you
I'm talking about within the last four
years where I could say no to something
Arthur's aren't there bits like oh that
sounds like way too much of a banger uh
yeah and then eventually I was like you
know what [__] it I'll pay whatever dues
I'll do whatever I need to do stop using
the term pay your dues yeah that relates
to your art okay that's a good point but
like but we're the new guys at jackass
turning down stunts on the j4 you guys
like arguing like fighting for more
screen time yeah yeah and that's not
even the new guys that's just all
everybody all the time unless Bulls are
involved and then nobody wants anything
yeah yeah I was that was just I was
curious about that genuine question of
like paying your dues in this game like
for for everybody that's trying to make
it like yeah there's no such thing
like I paid dues so like I don't share a
hotel room yeah you know I've paid my
dues so I actually traveled on my own
separate personal RV yeah but like I
it's not like yeah it's my dudes where
I'm not gonna build my crash capsule and
like for sure yeah yeah yeah and you got
tits yeah yeah leave the art out of it
yeah
like the payer dues has nothing to do
with you sticking your penis in that
animal yeah well you like that idea so
there's the laundry
okay
with thumbnail would that be just him
hugging a [__] big ant hill yeah okay
good I'm glad I asked now we can talk
about prostitutes
yeah easy
and let's leave out specific names of
who called who during the [__]
so on the first trip to Australia we met
up with my buddy Latham who's got this
like bone disease where his bones break
and I gave him a tattoo a lot of people
said I did a bad job but they were wrong
this time we met up with Latham to color
in his tattoo and he mentioned that the
last time I saw him
we had thrown around the idea of maybe
getting him some luck with the ladies
his DS yeah and it just so happens that
in in Australia prostitution
is legal well we didn't know that at
first
actually dude I I had forgotten but back
when jackass number two came out we were
shooting these uh promos for it we
actually went to a brothel like a a
whorehouse in Australia and screened
jackass number two for like all of the
the that's amazing that's so sick yeah
so I actually knew prostitution was
legal in Australia but I had forgotten
so
while I'm tattooing Latham he says oh
you know just so you know like uh I
still didn't you know and I was like oh
what are we talking about that he says
yeah
and I'm like all right well let's make
it happen
so I asked him any
I said you have any uh do what you do
best yeah yeah you're not dead might
let's find some so am I correct that you
Googled uh the city we were in which at
the time was Gladstone Gladstone
I think I said escorts escorts yeah and
it just showed up yeah and it gave me
like a couple websites and like a lot of
them are sketchy looking or all of them
were sketchy looking but I just started
dialing and texting and like every time
someone actually picked up the phone no
I I didn't I nobody answered but I was
getting replies via text and it's more
of like
yeah I'm available how long where are
you we happen to be in a hotel it was
like next door to their like principal
operating Hotel yeah right next door
right so we so so I give and and this
service was uh it was a hundred
Australian dollars per 15 minutes yes
which is pretty epic yeah so I said hey
you know Latham uh here's 200 so you can
have a half an hour plus here's a tip
you know an extra 40 bucks yeah so go
enjoy yourself yeah you know I'll have
nothing to do with being a big header so
laid them heads over next door yep
like uh as expected the lady opens up
the door Sees Latham in his wheelchair
and says Nope and shuts the door and
shuts the door when she was rude about
it too I I don't know I I think I mean
that is pretty rude just saying like yo
and shutting the door right you know uh
I mean at least I think so but I mean
but we did we didn't we struck out we
didn't specify what right the situation
was right so we struck out we went and
did the show that night and
um during the show and Lathan was pissed
he was just like do you believe this
[__] do you believe that do you believe
what she did yeah
he's the best and he was like trying to
give me the money back to give to you
and I'm just like no dude you keep it
like you said the boner and he's
punching holes through walls
so so uh I we had been planning on I
think leaving like that night or early
the next morning yeah and um yeah glass
in the mirror bro to pop your yeah what
we were gonna like have so I I during
the show during one of my videos I'm
like I'm backstage texting hey we're not
leaving this city we're gonna get the
job done right yeah you know until
Latham you know like uh stick around
like and so we stayed in Gladstone and
then the next day how many prostitutes
did we communicate with there's so many
yeah there's maybe 10. you're buying
look what do you have to do like some
will only accept like gas stations
excuse me
yeah one guy it was probably some
[__] dude scamming me he was like
okay cool like I don't take cash because
I'm like oh we're at the theater come
through and he's like he's like great
I'm like we got the cash he's like oh I
don't take cash I take a gift card so
I'm like all right so I went to the gas
station I [__] went to the ATM got
cash
yeah give the lady the money got the
gift card and then he and on the way
back I'm like yeah I got the gift card
he's like already that dude must have
been hot I mean I thought it was a girl
you know and he's like oh why don't you
tell me you're going to get gift cards I
I want an Apple gift card I'm like well
I have a United gift card he's like well
send me the yeah so that was about so
you knew you were talking to a dude I
mean I would I know but like
I mean I figured because it was like a
scam
no no I always watch scammer paybacks
and they make you do things on so I
figured as a dude so then when we
finally found the actual lady for the
job
it was the next day it was the next day
and she was the only person that we're
communicating with that said call me and
oh
there's crossed that all of the
video uh the prison pocket video like
it's probably gonna be a little bit
tricky and and uh hopefully this video
doesn't just get buried for uh for some
of the stuff we've talked about but hey
what are you gonna do yeah
um so yeah so we called her and I just
said you know I asked her hey we got a
guy laid them we wanted to take care of
him he's a virgin she's like yeah no
problem and then he says hey I I'm not
used to this kind of stuff I was like
are you a cop do I have to ask you if
you're a cop she's like no but I dressed
up like one sometimes
and then she was explaining to us the
laws right right and and uh like we've
stuck her behind uh like the not the
curtain but the the blind
yeah the dead blinds yeah so you can see
just a silhouette of her explaining the
legality of prostitution yeah in
Australia and she said there's brothels
and there's freelance which are both
legal and she's the freelance version
where she has all of her licenses or
whatever she's licensed I mean it's epic
so she she was super cool about uh
explaining on you know on camera with
without her identity being revealed we
told her we wanted to have a Latham on
camera when the deed was done to see his
facial reaction
um turns out we had like three cameras
she was fine with it totally cool with
everything so it was labeled oh my God
so late so I I'm gone at this point I
went off to go and get some food or
something
and
I and and I'm getting reports back like
is the deed done and uh Scott says he
nutted twice yeah I'm like wait dude
this is the greatest thing in the world
because
there was potential for this to be like
something that was kind of uncomfortable
maybe like oh we think this is going to
be a great video like oh dude like like
it's in for like there was there was a
possibility that it would feel like we
were kind of exploiting Latham for for
content and that like pulling him into
getting a hooker yeah right right and
Not only was that not the case but he
loved it so much that he was finished
with the whole operation within 20
seconds he said and he had a half an
hour
so he said hey would you mind if we do
that again and and this lady was so cool
she was so sick you bet yeah yeah you
paid for the half hour why not yeah so
so then like the whole thing like over
the fact that it happened twice is is
genuinely indicative that it was not
in any way a bummer no yeah of course
not and he's on camera like when she
walks at the walks out like the door
closes and he Zips in his little
electric wheelchair straight over the
camera and he's like [__] yeah dude
wasn't he like sucking her titties and
slapping her butt I don't know I've not
seen his cider but is that true yeah
yeah
for sure wow I know I I did dude he's
such a legend dude I saw a still shot on
the camera just as a freeze frame where
he's holding her hair
yeah you got a little into it
[Laughter]
and bless his heart yeah dude bless his
heart and uh what a week like I said
what a week yeah and um
it's my birthday tomorrow I turned 40. I
know it's gonna be crazy I am aware of
that it is in my calendar on repeat
every year and um yeah I don't even want
to do anything but it's another crazy
week but maybe we can get dinner tonight
or something or like I I had it in my
calendar I knew it was coming Jeremy hit
me up yesterday he said hey you want to
do something big for not because I care
about you or your birthday but it is an
opportunity for killer content
[Laughter]
I don't know can you do like either you
know try to hug a kangaroo or do the
glory hole beehive I'll do whatever you
need me to do thank you yeah why don't
you it's good I don't want him he's like
how am I gonna fit this monster in that
little animal
how am I gonna fit this baseball bat
all right well uh I think um I thought
that was a fun one and I like being in
Australia I like being in Australia
um I kind of just hope bam doesn't die I
really do I really would wish man it's
not too late it's never too late man
yeah it's never too late to get it no of
course not if anything like the worst
things get the better the hope is for
yeah
so it's pretty [__] bad it's pretty
bad um real quick this comes out
tomorrow correct no I think today's
Tuesday
uh it's now after midnight on Wednesday
morning in America okay you got shows
coming up and it's 11 p.m Tuesday night
right now okay yeah so and and we got
some shows coming up in Australia that
you might want to send traffic to
like there's one
third show that we added in truralgon
trollagong Charlotte uh uh I mean
whatever dude if you're in Australia
there's a chance to catch us and the
show is literally epic if you're in the
UK I was just gonna say if you wanted to
say anything about the UK like a
pre-sale is just on
and I did like I was told not to promote
the pre-sale for the UK because they
have some weird rule you can only um
uh pre-sell 30 of the tickets and
they're like dude those things are gone
whoa that's so sick so it's like
pre-size if you want to be a part of the
pre-sale you got it if you know you know
yeah I'm not even allowed to promote it
they said so yeah so yeah dudes fun
times yeah there it is I'll do my outro
right here and how about that would you
believe that and thank you for sticking
around to the end man my beautiful
street team
you good job Benny I don't think it was
an outrageous statement to say that that
was arguably
one of if not the most entertaining
episodes ever I think so I am a man it's
crazy and I'll leave you guys with this
man like I really am genuinely terrified
when I wake up in the morning to open up
my phone and what am I gonna am I gonna
see that headline that that I'm dreading
maybe you know what people recover man
people recover all the time there's no
such thing as being a lost cause in the
game of addiction man and
um I I tried everything I could I tried
everything I could and I just couldn't
you know I can't do it but hopefully
what's going on now is enough to finally
get our body back and uh I'm just saying
fingers crossed man all kidding aside
dude I don't want bam to die I don't
want I want him back he could have a
good life still he could have a really
amazing life so I love you guys thanks
for sticking around